[Applaus]
hier hat sie gelebt in einer ländlichen
Gemeinde nicht weit entfernt vom
genferee ein ruhiges Leben eine
liebevolle Familie ein Leben ohne
größere
Ereignisse adelin wurde 34 Jahre
alt jetzt ist sie nicht mehr da und doch
so präsent in den Herzen jener die sich
am 10 September versammeln um ihrer zu
gedenken die Emotionen sind so stark wie
am ersten Tag auch nach 10 Jahren man
hat uns unser Licht des Lebens
genommen seit leben wir in
[Musik]
Traurigkeit
12 September
2013 die sozialtherapeutin Adeline
Morell begleitet einen Häftling auf
Freigang der Mann wurde wegen zwei
Vergewaltigungen verurteilt sein Name
Fabris
a
das Ziel des Ausflugs eine
Reittherapie unterwegs halten Sie an
einem Geschäft Fabris a hat einen
Hufkratzer bestellt doch letztlich ist
es ein Messer das er
kauft gemeinsam mit adelin macht sich
der Häftling wieder auf den Weg zum
Reithof dort jedoch kommen sie nie
an der Ausflug endet am Rande eines
Waldes in den Ermittlungs steht was dann
geschah sie fuhren zu einem verlassenen
Haus als adelin merkte dass etwas nicht
stimmte griff sie nach ihrem Handy er
tauchte hinter ihr auf und hielt ihr das
Messer vors Gesicht zweimal sagte sie
nein Fabris sagte ihr dass er ihr nicht
weh tun sondern nur aus dem Gefängnis
flüchten
wolle später während der Beweisaufnahme
erklärt
FA ich habe sie fesselt sitzend die Arme
nach hinten irgendwann ging meine linke
Hand wie von selbst nach unten ich habe
sie angesehen es war wie ein schwarzer
Schleier dann hat meine Hand sich
selbständig
gemacht
adelin wird am nächsten Tag mit
durchgeschnittener Kehle aufgefunden die
Schweiz steht unter Schock vier Monate
zuvor hatte ein rückfälliger Krimineller
eine 19-jährige ermordet und jetzt
adelin einmal mehr Horror und
Entsetzen diesmal mit einem anderen
[Musik]
Vornamen der Fall adlin ist nicht nur
der Fall adlin es ist der Tod einer
Mutter einer Lebensgefährtin einer
Tochter einer
Schwester das sage ich immer wieder wenn
man v
denn letztendlich ist es viel mehr als
[Applaus]
das jedes Jahr am 14 März backe ich ihr
einen
Geburtstagskuchen das mache ich weiter
auch seit sie gestorben
ist es nützt nichts man muss nach vorne
schauen koste es was es
wolle 10 Jahre sind eine lange
Zeit wir vermissen sie seit 10
Jahren aber dafür wachsen die anderen
Kinder und die Enkelkinder
heran das ist das was uns den Rhythmus
der Jahre
vorgibt wir haben vier
Enkelkinder aber es ist so dass eins von
ihnen keine Mutter mehr
hat
[Musik]
adelin Partner Juan hat seine Frau und
seinen Lebensentwurf
[Musik]
verloren das war ein Bruch in meinem
Leben alles wurde auf den Kopf gestellt
ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können
meine Tochter ohne Mutter groß zuuziehen
oder dass meine Frau unter solchen
Umständen sterben würde dass ich ihre
Eltern
ich kann nicht mehr
sprechen das alles war unvorstellbar ich
habe mir auch nicht vorgestellt dass ich
meine Karriere aufgeben würde eine neue
Welt aufbauen um das alles zu
überleben das alles habe ich mir niemals
vorstellen
können Juan schreibt an seiner
Geschichte sein Buch die Verarbeitung
des
Erlebten es gibt die Trauer daran
arbeite ich aber es ist die Art und
Weise wie sie gestorben
ist man hat sie
gedemütigt sie starb unter unwürdigen
Bedingungen unter den Augen von jemandem
der es genossen hat ihr beim Sterben
zuzusehen er hat sich diese Szene immer
wieder vorgestellt und alles geplant
sie ist allein einen schrecklichen Tod
gestorben fabriis a wurde 2017 zu
lebenslanger Freiheitsstrafe und
ordentlicher Verwahrung
[Musik]
verurteilt es fällt mir schwer ihn als
Menschen zu bezeichnen er ist kein
Mensch er ist
böse werden immer noch davon heim
gesucht wie sie gestorben ist sie hat
die Verkörperung des Bösen erlebt das
ist es was uns
verfolgt fabriis a ein Monster der Mord
an adelin hat die Debatte über
rückfällige schwere Straftäter neu
entfacht wer sind diese Personen ist es
vorstellbar dass sie jemals wieder
freigelassen
werden
sie das ist eine grundlegende und
schwierige Frage in der Psychiatrie
dieser Gegensatz den die Engländer m
nennen
panteleonanakopulus hat Fabr nicht
begutachtet aber er ist eine Autorität
in der Psychiatrie insbesondere im
Bereich
derschenungenon e Frage zurück die
menschlich und verständlich ist ist
jemand böse oder
verrückt für den Menschen ist es
schwierig sich vorzustellen dass jemand
böse sein kann ohne psychisch krank zu
sein ist fabrriis a also verrückt oder
Böse in dem psychiatrischen Gutachten
die nach dem Mord an adelin von Fabr
erstellt wurden wird ein Mann
beschrieben der von seinem Hass auf
Frauen und seinem Kontrollzwang
beherrscht
wird einige Sätze des Mörders geben
Aufschluss über seine gespaltene
Persönlichkeit am Tag des Mordes war ich
mr Hyde heute bin ich Dr jackhill ich
war krank genug um sie zu töten und bin
gesund genug um es zu
[Musik]
bereuen AMAG der als er Adel
fesselt das Ziel war bei ihr eine Panik
auszulösen ich wollte durch ihre Angst
Kontrolle über sie
erlangen adelin war unter seiner
Kontrolle warum also sie
töten weil sie meine Fantasie beflügelt
hat und ich diese mörderischen Impulse
hatte das was ich getan habe macht man
nur wenn man ein Sadist ist
die Experten nehmen das Leben des
Mörders unter die Lupe sie treffen sich
mit ihm befragen seine Angehörigen und
Bekannten nehmen Einsicht in seine
Strafakten ihre Diagnose Fabris a hat
eine ausgeprägte Neigung zu
Sadomasochismus und weist starke
psychopathische Züge
auf Fabris a hat eine disoziale
Persönlichkeitsstörung
was man als dieoziale Persönlichkeit
bezeichnet sind Menschen die wiederholt
im Gefängnis landen oder mit dem Gesetz
in Konflikt
geraten das sind Personen die andere
körperlich oder verbal
angreifen die große Schwierigkeiten
haben sich der Gesellschaft
anzupassen wenn Sie das tun dann nur um
einen Gewinn zu
erzielen oft auf Kosten
[Musik]
anderer damit dieagn soalen
Persönlichkeit zutrifft muss man bereits
als Kind oder Jugendlicher eine
Verhaltensstörung
aufweisen das heißt man muss bereits in
der Schule oder sehr jung mit dem Gesetz
oder den Regeln in Konflikt geraten das
ist wichtig weil wir das als eine Art
Fehler im System eines Menschen sehen
der sich dann
weiterentwickelt wurde Fabr mit diesem
Fehler im System geboren wahrscheinlich
ja sagen Experten jedenfalls leide er
nicht an einer psychischen Krankheit im
klassischen
[Musik]
Sinne seine Entwicklung in einer
dysfunktionalen Familie erschwert die
Dinge seine Schulzeit verläuft holprig
er wird zum Kleinkriminellen immer neue
Gelegenheitsjobs er ist instabil und
macht anderen Angst er verführt geht
aber nie eine Beziehung auf Augenhöhe
ein ein Element löst bei den Psychiatern
Alarm aus der Moment in dem fabriis
adelin tötet löst bei ihm eine Art
Orgasmus aus eine
allmachtsorgie und dieses lustvolle
Gefühl so die Experten kann fabrriis nur
erreichen wenn er seine schrecklichen
Taten aufs Neue
ausführt Fab hat dies verstanden und
nicht ausgeschlossen dass er ein
Serienmörder werden
könnte spter hat diese jedoch
verworfen die Gefahr eines Rückfalls ist
somit gegeben es stellt sich die Frage
ob dieses Verhalten korrigiert werden
kann die Experten sind sich
einig beim begutachteten ist in
erheblichem und dauerhaftem Maße eine
sadistische und perverse Grausamkeit
vorhanden ausgelöst durch das Gefühl der
Allmacht über den
anderen dies macht es äußerst schwierig
wenn nicht g möglich wirkungsvolle
therapeutische Maßnahmen zur
Verminderung der Rückfallgefahr zu
[Musik]
ergreifen es gibt also keine Therapie
die bei dem Mörder von adelin wirksam
wäre das erklärt das schwere Urteil das
Fabris a erhalten
hat zunächst die lebenslange
Freiheitsstrafe nach 15 Jahren wird eine
bedingte Freilassung geprüft diese wird
jedoch nur selten gewährt
solange adelins Mörder im Vollzug der
lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe ist ruht
sozusagen die Verwahrung beide
Sanktionen sind unbegrenzt der
verurteilte Mörder kommt mit sehr großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit nie mehr auf freien
Fuß neben der lebenslangen
Freiheitsstrafe wurde Fabris a zu der in
Artikel 64 Absatz 1 des Strafgesetzbuchs
vorgesehenen sichernden Maßnahme
verurteilt der ordentlichen
Verwahrung diese muss grundlegende
Bedingungen erfüllen der Täter muss ein
schweres Gewalt oder Sexualverbrechen
begangen haben und das Rückfallrisiko
muss hoch sein vor allem aber bei einer
Verwahrung geht das Gericht davon aus
dass der Täter nicht therapierbar
ist die Maßnahme der Verwahrung wird
angetreten nachdem der Gefangene seine
Strafe verbüß hat ihre Dauer ist enzt
jedes Jahr wird geprüft ob der
Verurteilte entlassen werden kann dies
ist jedoch sehr selten der Fall die
Wahscheinlichkeit ist somit hoch dass
Fabris a das Gefängnis nie mehr
verlassen
wird warum also hat adelins Familie
Angst dass fabriis A erneut zuschlagen
könnte diese Angst ist sehr stark sie
wird jedes Jahr größer weil ich weiß
dass ihn bisher niemand im Griff hatte
das ist ein außergewöhnlicher
Manipulator der Beweis dafür ist dass er
wieder einen Skandal ausgelöst hat
dieser Mann macht mir
Angst am 16 Mai lässt eine Genfer
Zeitung die Bombe
platzen fabriis a hat aus dem Gefängnis
heraus erneut eine Frau
belästigt eine Frau aus dem
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis im kantonzug
heraus
belästigen ist das
möglich im Frühjahr gibt Fabris
telefonisch eine lebensmittelbestellung
auf in dem gelieferten Paket ist ein
Werbeprospekt enthalten darin ist eine
Verkäuferin abgebildet Fabris schafft es
sich die Kontaktdaten der jungen Frau zu
beschaffen er schreibt ihr ruft sie an
er wird immer
aufdringlicher als klar wird wer der
Stalker istiert das Ladenpersonal
im Zuger Gefängnis erhält lediglich
einen Verweis er habe nicht gegen die
Regeln verstoßen unter bestimmten
Bedingungen habe auch ein verwarter nach
Artikel 64 das Recht auf Telefon Post
und Internet den noch für die
Angehörigen von adelin ein weiterer
dolstoß dies K ist überhaupt nichtt er
hat sichull
verer daür dass man mit so jemandem
nichts mehr anfangen
kann man denkt 10 Jahre können jemanden
weich klopfen aber nichts da 20 Jahre 30
Jahre ich habe das Gefühl dass den nur
das Alter ruhig stellen
kann wenn sowas wieder passassiert wäre
es als ob man ad nochmals töten
würde das löst in mir eine Menge aus das
ist nicht rational aber so fühle
ich tief in seinem Inneren ist Juan
nicht wirklich erstaunt über das was
passiert ist in seinem früheren Leben
war er ebenfalls Sozialtherapeut im
Gefängnis und in Kontakt mit einem
gewissen fabriis
a ich kannte ihn ein Jahr lang genau wie
ad er war unser Klient unser
Patient man muss weder böse sein ih
verzeihen er ist so wie er ist man muss
ihn nur einsperren es gibt Gefangene die
darf man nie mehr
freilassen es gibt sie tatsächlich die
Gefangenen die nie mehr freikommen für
diese Schwerverbrecher mit gestörter
Persönlichkeit ist der Artikel 64 Absatz
1 ein oneway Ticket zur endgültigen
Wegsperrung die Gesellschaft soll vor
ihnen geschützt werden für
immer eine männerwg beim
Znacht heute gibt es
düm für das wochenendmenü sind
Vorschläge
willkommen also deumschnitzel W
gut Nudel
jafall
ja
es ist eine geschlossene Gesellschaft
der besonderen Art eine WG für verwarte
die einzige in der
Schweiz die Justizvollzugsanstalt
soloturn im ehemaligen Direktorenhaus
begann vor 3 Jahren das Pilotprojekt
sechs verwarte leben hier gemeinsam es
sind schweizweit bekannte
[Musik]
Fälle ihre Taten brutal
skrupellos alle waren zuvor in anderen
Anstalten Jahrzehnte
lang aus im and Gefängnis von ich vorher
da Spieß und m K und beschränkt und so
und hier ist das natürlich vom ganz
Aufbau her natürlich sch einfacher und
fr ja
ja quitteren und stürmen also quter sich
St wei nicht verwaht wird wer eine
schwere Gewalt oder Sexualstraftat
begeht und dazu als Rückfall gefährdet
und nicht therapierbar gilt ist die
Haftstrafe verbüßt bleibt der Täter
hinter Gittern zum Schutz der
Gesellschaft
was tun mit Menschen die vielleicht ihr
Leben lang im Gefängnis bleiben
werden Besuch bei Marcel der eigentlich
anders
heißt sch das VI jahrhundert im
Gefängnis und verurteilt sind
was jeden Tag spielt Marcel sein
Lieblingsspiel Solitär
er spielt immer dasselbe Level
Internetzugang hat er
nicht das ist m Bett und das ist es Rück
schon schon
Kopf wo mir
hier stüze
und
tempratzef die breit
die die
pasüensffen dar er was er selbst
bezahlen kann solang dass der Weg noch
fre für zum Bett oder so W irgend
W ja kan ja sie dass sie
herzinfarktkommen od weiß nicht Wasus
auch seine Arbeit hinter Gittern darf
Marcel mitbestimmen Tag für Tag geht er
auf
aschenbecherrunde
machen das noch
ger und bew und
ja Schw
und das
gut es git sicher zuschau s das doch
nicht das Verw Freiheit und woh ja aber
ja das ist groß Thema
nicht was ich dazu
sag ich fühle
michzügig
dass Stra ab das
eigent
sch doch welche Hafterleichterungen
sollen verwarte haben auf diese Frage
sucht unter anderem der Direktor der JV
solot eine
Antwort nach der Verb von der
Stra
w und Verw heißt eigentlich n dass die
Personen Freiheit entlassen wer ist
nicht das fair
wenn wenigstens Inter nach vor sicher
Rahmen mit wenigstens in dass ganze
settingau ein Setting mitonderen
Privilegien die män selst sieen sie
Kochen mit Messern und sie surfen unter
Aufsicht im
Internet auch einen Garten hat die WG
ein idyllisches Leben im
Gefängnis das Zusammenleben gestaltet
sich gut die Bewohner schätzen die WG
sehr eine WG in der sechs
Schwerverbrecher
Zusammenleben das bewiest ja auch dass
das nicht nur um menensche
sind
natürlich das ist ees Zimmer
ja das ist mleine Zimmer ich hab
Aussicht gerade auf der Berg W immer
wieder Spaziergänger vah also W ich da
bin hab ich nur gesagt
wow was ist das
da und für mich sind das einfach zwei
wel ich bin in verschiedene
Anstalten und man merkt s dass man
einfach immer
eschrankt und und und dass die husorde
einfach zu restriktiv
sind seit mehr als 30 Jahren lebt Marcel
hintergittan mag Musik ich mag Radio
Nachrichten ich muss einfach informiert
se ich habe zwar kein Fernseh aber das
heißt nicht dass ich nicht informiert
bin un der Fernseh wir ob
Imin
gemeinsam Fernseh und der nicht benutze
er weiß wie umstritten seine Freiheiten
sind Gesellschaft W D se l wo z m
begangen die S schön das kann ich Bissen
gerade noch volollziehen das ist ganz
klar ich hab Mord begangen ich hab
ich hab
ST J ambul Therapie wo ich
ersttinstandzlich akzeptiert hab ich hat
die 16 Jahr hinter mir ohne
vollzugslockrie
PU vor zwei Jahren erkämpfte sich Marcel
mit einer Beschwerde seinen Platz in der
WG das Bundesgericht entschied zudem der
Kanton müsse prüfen ob seine Verwahrung
in anderen Gefängnissen vorher
menschenrechtskonform
war ein wegweisender Entscheid für die
Schweiz
ja guten
morgenm
bitte danke
schön Marcel verbringt Teile des Tages
zusammen mit anderen verwarten die nicht
in der WG wohnen nach dem Umziehen
geht's an die
Arbeit find alle verwart so Abteil sind
ja ich danke alleIch behandel müsste das
sie
die das die andere es ist noch lang
nicht jeder Verw l Wege sich bew es wird
immer Verw im
strafzug Setting sicherheitüberleg m
bben W sie sich
sozialf beweg wo sie immer wieder
aggressiv sie provokativ sie auchenüber
den anderen
ins Konzept D
wür verwart die wird
Pass ein Platz in der VG kostet fast 600
Franken pro Tag das ist doppelt so viel
wie im normalen
Strafvollzug
warum das hat bis mit mit der Größe von
V der Wohngruppe zu das ist das ist s se
Platz und wen man das natürlich im ganze
vost V rech Macht über das Ganze also
die ganze
Sicherheitsinfrastruktur die ganz ganze
Sicherheitspersonal nach
betreuchlüssel wenn man dast wird das
einür du immerin stell ich weiß aber du
we ich sch gar nicht muss ja nicht ich
habkt d
falsche ja
ja verwter bleibt ein Mensch und der
Rechtsstaat muss ihn als Menschen
behandeln Benjamin Breer ist einer der
führenden Schweizer Experten für den
Strafvollzug der Rechtsstaat ist der
Auffassung dass du gefährlich bist du
bist im Gefängnis verwartt und wirst
dort bleiben aber trotzdem bist du ein
Mensch der Rechte hat und eines davon
sind Lebensbedingungen die an eine so
lange hazeit en
sind nur wenige verwarte kommen je
wieder auf freien Fuß auch in der JV
solotor dennoch geben einige Insassen
ihre Hoffnung nicht
auf ja die hoffn kan nach wie vor und
der Glaube will es für mich existentiell
ist existentiell in dem Sinn das
auch Familie aubt und und ich B mus bben
und eventuell übervollzugslock Krieger
und dann
bedingtlass
D zurück zum verwarten auf Aschenbecher
Tour seine Vollzugsbehörde prüfte ihn in
eine offene Anstalt zu verlegen doch sie
kam zum Schluss dass er dort überfordert
wäref ja das wirklich im sin also
wenn gravieren passiert oder nicht
irgend das Wunder passiert oder weiß
nicht was aber ich bin Fred da ich hoffe
ich zigunde macht ke Angst W den da ster
ne absolut
nicht theoretisch könnte auch der Mörder
von adelin in einigen Jahren in eine
solche VG
umziehen in der Schweiz gibt es unter
Inhaftierten etwa 150 verwarte die als
nicht therapierbar eingestuft werden
Mörder
Vergewaltiger zu ihnen gehört auch
fabrriis a die Familie von adelin macht
sich große
[Musik]
Sorgen er ist ein großer Manipulator ein
intelligenter Mann und er wird es
schaffen wieder herauszukommen niemand
kann mich vom Gegenteil
überzeugen
tatsächlich könnte adelins Mutter recht
haben theoretisch könnte Fabris a wieder
freigelassen
werden tatsache ist jedoch dass die
Freilassung eines verwarten heute kaum
mehr
vorkommt Martin ist eine Ausnahme aus
der Verwahrung in die Freiheit er weiß
dass seine Aussagen schockieren und
seine Freilassung beunruhigt
ich wurde wegen Vergewaltigung und
sexueller Übergriffe
verurteilt mehrere
Vergewaltigungen er Instanz habe ich 18
Jahre
bekommen am Ende waren es dann 12 Jahre
und ein Artikel
64fähritit alle Warnlampen stehen zum
Zeitpunkt seiner Verurteilung auf Rot
Martin Störungen sind tiefgreifend und
sie haben einen
Namen narzisstische Perversion Tendenz
Borderline im Grunde genommen ist es das
das ist keine Krankheit die man mit
Medikamenten behandeln
kann das ist eine psychische Störung
eine tiefgreifende
Persönlichkeitsstörung
mat hat sich nie gegen Therapien
gestäubt im
Gegenteil ich habe an allen Therapien
teilgenommen man muss dazu sagen dass es
mir in der ersten Zeit nicht so gut
ging im Gefängnis geht es einem nie gut
aber ich musste erst einmal Aufwachen
aus dem was ich getan
hatte an sich arbeiten und sich bewusst
sein dass es ein langer Weg wird
Gefängnis hin oder
her im Gefängnis arbeitet Martin über
die Jahre hinweg an sich selbst die
Ärzte beurteilen ihn regelmäßig und
ändern schließlich ihre Einschätzung
Martin Persönlichkeitsstörung kann
stabilisiert werden seine Gefährlichkeit
und das Rückfallrisiko nehmen ab nach
einer gerichtlichen Überprüfung wird die
Verwahrung nach Artikel 64 auf Artikel
59 umgewandelt das ändert alles
zumindest
zunächst der Artikel 59 des
schweizerischen Strafgesetzbuchs
betrifft die stationären therapeutischen
Maßnahmen von psychisch gestörten
Straftätern der Täter muss ein schweres
Verbrechen begangen haben das mit der
psychischen Störung im Zusammenhang
steht und es muss ein Rückfallrisiko
bestehen im Gegensatz zu Artikel 64 der
Verwahrung muss mus die verurteilte
Person jedoch therapierbar
sein eine Umstufung von Artikel 64 auf
59 ist selten es mag wie ein kleiner
Schritt aussehen aber es ist ein
riesiger Erfolg wenn man es schafft
einen Richter dazu zu bringen einen
Artikel 64 in einen Artikel 59
umzuwandeln das ist sehr schwierig die
Hürde ist sehr
hoch es ist machbar aber ser
selten nach langen Jahren der
Inhaftierung beginnt Mar von einem Leben
ohne Gitterstäbe zu träumen er ist nur
wenige Schritte davon entfernt seine
psychiatrischen Beurteilungen sind
ermutigend dann geschieht das
Unvorstellbare Fabris a tötet
adelin die Politi kon strafvzugsbehörden
ziehen sofort die
Schrauben
dieleitä werden ausges ebenso die
bedingten Freilassungen Mar ist zu
diesem Zeitpunkt seit fast 15 Jahren
inhaftiert sein neuer Lebensentwurf
Gerät in wanken sein Anwalt
kritisiert der tragische Fall adlin hat
die Gerichts und verwaltungslandschaft
völlig
verändert es gibt ein vor dieser
Tragödie und ein
danach Strafe abgesessen die Verwahrung
wurde zu Gunsten einer stationären
therapeutischen Maßnahme
aufgehoben und dann so viele Jahre nach
seiner Tat für die er verurteilt und
bestraft
wurde steht er immer noch unter
Maßnahmen auch wenn diese in den letzten
Jahren Schritt für Schritt gelockert
wurden aber 27 Jahre so viele Jahre das
ist enorm
die durchschnittliche Dauer der
Maßnahmen nach einem Artikel 59 oder 64
ist in den letzten 15 Jahren erheblich
angestiegen seit er den Strafvollzug
beobachtet hat Benjamin breger erlebt
wie sich die Prioritäten verändert
haben heute geht es mehr um die
Sicherheit und die Vermeidung eines
Rückfalls man will das risikopotenal bei
einer Freilassung besser
einschätzen es wird sehr genau abgeklärt
ob ein Täter weiter gefährlich ist und
wieder ein Verbrechen begehren könnte
die Vollzugsbehörden waren früher
vielleicht ein wenig lasch dafür sind
sie heute ziemlich streng vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen zu
streng heute werden mehr therapeutische
Maßnahmen im Sinne von Artikel 59
ausgesprochen als früher es ist als
würde die Psychiatrie der Justiz zur
Hilfe eilen um einen Menschen der das
Gesetz achtet zu neutralisieren erklärt
man ihn für
verrückt um uns Sicherheit zu geben ist
es besser zu denken dass das mä
vorherrscht das Wahnsinn hinter einer
Tat
steckt aber oft ist das nicht der Fall
man fragt sich gibt es Bosheit auch ohne
Wahnsinn deshalb haben die
therapeutischen Maßnahmen in den letzten
drei Jahrzehnten so
zugenommen 1984 fanden sich 13 Personen
mit psychischen Störungen nach Artikel
59 im
Maßnahmenvollzug heute sind es laut den
Zahlen des Bundesamts für Statistik über
700 wenn das so weitergeht werden wir in
ein paar Jahren mehr als 2000 Personen
im Maßnahmenvollzug haben das kann ich
die Lösung sein wir sollten mit den
heutigen Instrumenten in der Lage sein
zu sehen ob jemand wirklich gefährlich
ist und keine Fortschritte macht oder ob
man ihn oder sie zurück in die Freiheit
begleiten
kann wir brauchen eine neue Kultur des
Vertrauens kein naives vertrauen sondern
ein wohlüberlegtes
Vertrauen eine Sanktion die kein Ende
nimmt Artikel 59 hat einen Spitznamen
die kleine Verwahrung gegen sie wehrt
sich die Genfer Anwältin ja haat
glauben Sie denn dass die Kriminellen
von gestern komplett anders sind als die
Kriminellen von
heute es ist unser Blick der sich
verändert hat Verbrechen hat es immer
gegeben aber unser Blick auf die
Menschen hat sich mit der Zeit
verändert ich verstehe natürlich dass es
Fälle gibt die um uns herum Angst und
Terror verbreitet
haben die Maßnahmen die daraufin im
wurden sind eine Antwort darauf und ganz
offensichtlich vor allem von Angst
gesteuert man muss ich also eine
wichtige Frage
stellen ist es richtig dass die Behörden
als Konsequenz gewisser Fälle Urteile
fällen die mehr von Emotionen als von
der Vernunft geleitet
werden für Martin besteht kein Zweifel
er musste für diese Politik
bezahlen für mich ist das eine direkte
Konsequenz aus dem Fall adlin eine Art
Übereifer um die Bevölkerung zu
beruhigen man sagt den Leuten sozusagen
schaut die lassen wir nicht mehr
raus seit Ende Dezember ist Martin von
seinen Maßnahmen befreit und auf freiem
Fuß fühlt er sich vor ein Rückfall
sicher der Martin der immerhin
Persönlichkeitsstörungen hatte er wird
sicherlich sein ganzes Leben lang damit
zu tun haben er wird damit leben müssen
das wird nicht völlig
verschwinden aber er hat über die Jahre
gelernt zumindest herauszufinden und in
Worte zu fassen warum er so ist warum er
diese Persönlichkeitsstörungen hat
deshalb würde ich sagen er ist ziemlich
geläutert der alte Martin ist sehr
geschwächt ich glaube so kann man das
sagen martin hatte viele Jahre Zeit zum
Nachdenken man muss schon sagen eine
Therapie ist etwas
egoistisches etwas das man vor allem für
sich selbst und erst danach für andere
macht aber man denkt dabei immer an die
Opfer in meinem Leben und im Leben der
Opfer ist etwas Schlimmes passiert das
nicht wier gut gemacht werden kann egal
was man sagt nur weil ich eine Therapie
mache heißt das nicht dass sich die
Opfer besser
fühlen sein Anwalt begleitet Martin
schon seit
Prozessbeginn er ist
zuversichtlich ich bin überzeugt dass
Martin nicht rückfällig werden
wird seine psychotherapeutische Arbeit
und seine Schritte zur
Wiedereingliederung in die Gesellschaft
waren
beispielhaft er hat einen
außergewöhnlichen Willen und ich bin
davon überzeugt er schafft
das Überzeugung allein wird nicht
reichen was ist wenn Martin wie andere
vor ihm erneut eine Straftat begeht
erneut vergewaltigt wer wäre
verantwortlich der Richter der über die
Entlassung entschieden hat oder die
Psychiater mit positiven
Gutachten
irgendwann muss jemand seine
Unterschrift setzen das kann man drehen
und wenden wie man will es gibt einen
Punkt an dem es getan werden muss das
ist zwar immer Teamarbeit aber einer
muss am Ende die Verantwortung
übernehmen das ist eine schwer zu
übernehm der
Verantwortung die Angst vor den
Konsequenzen und die Angst vor den
Medien wenn die Dinge dann schiefgehen
sollen
Dramen über Rückfälligkeit von
Straftätern findet man schnell aber wer
interessiert sich für erfolgreiche
wiedere
eingliederungen der genferpsychiater
weiß dass es sie gibt er ist der
medizinische Leiter der
strafvolzugsanstalt
kurabilis die Anstalt wurde kurz nach
dem tragischen Tod von adelin eingeweiht
und ist die einzige gesicherte
forensischpsychiatrische
maßnahmenstation in der
Westschweiz in den R Plätzen werden
speziell Straftäter mit psychischen
Störungen untergebracht sie sind im
Gefängnis und in intensiver
therapeutischer
Betreuung jedes Jahr verlassen 30 bis 40
von ihnen kurabilis in die Freiheit sie
sind stabilisiert und können so die
Gutachten in der Gesellschaft erneut
funktionieren micha ist einer von
ihnen er hat seine Strafe verbüß und ist
wieder auf freiem
Fuß hat mein Leben
gerettet ich bin zufrieden ich bin
glücklich und ich fühle mich schon viel
freier ich freue mich auf das was kommt
meine neuen
Lebensprojekte hat die Letten Jahre
vorher lebte er in einer Beziehung ging
seiner Arbeit nach aber in seinem Kopf
herrschte Chaos und immer wieder
entstand aus dem Chaos das
Verbrechen ich hatte
warvorstellungen und fühlte mich
verfolgt Kommunikation war für mich
manchmal
unmöglich dazu kamen
psychffektiveungen Bindung mit
psychotischen
Zuständen eines Tages war ich in einem
solchen Zustand und habe meine Freundin
angegriffen ich hörte Stimmen die mir
befahlen meine Freundin zu
töten ich habe zwar versucht mich
dagegen zu wehren aber am Ende bin ich
zur Tat geschritten ich habe ihr mit
einem Hammer auf den Kopf
geschlagen und dann versucht sie zu
erwirkgen
sie hat mich angefliht aufzuhören da
habe ich eingehalten und einen
Krankenwagen für sie und die Polizei für
mich
gerufen zum Zeitpunkt der Tat ist Micha
31 Jahre alt für den versuchten Mord
wird er zuur einer mehrjährigen
Freiheitsstrafe und einer Maßnahme gemäß
Artikel 59 verurteilt er gilt als gut
therapierbar nach einigen Monaten in
einem Genfer Gefängnis kommt er in eine
Zelle von
kurabilis dort beginnt seine Arbeit an
sich
selbst einer der Hauptfaktoren war das
gegenseitige Vertrauen zwischen mir und
meinen
Betreuern das hat es ermöglicht auch
sehr schwierige Themen
anzugehen wir haben viel Wissen über
meine Krankheit ausgetauscht und daran
gearbeitet meine auseinandergebrochene
Persönlichkeit zu
flicken wir haben auch an meiner
suchtpatik
AR wir haben verstanden dass ich Alkohol
oft gegen Angst und Einsamkeit
konsumiert habe und Cannabis gegen meine
Phobien wir auch viel über meine Familie
und meine Freunde gesprochen so konnte
ich nach und nach die Beziehungen zu
ihnen wieder
aufbauen
micha hat sich mit dem Leiden seines
Opfers seiner ehemaligen Lebensgefährtin
[Musik]
auseinandergesetzt sie hatte tramatische
Erlebnisse mit mir der Höhepunkt war
natürlich meine
tat ich fühle mich schuldig ich bere
alles was ich angetan
habeerelich iche sie zu
töten das hinterlässt Spuren für das
ganze
Leben es motiviert mich auf mich selbst
aufzupassen damit sich so etwas nicht
wiederholt das was passiert ist ist eine
Lektion für mich ich weiß heute in
welchen Situationen es gefährlich werden
könnte
seit dem Interview hat Micha die Schweiz
mit dem Einverständnis seiner Ärzte und
der Gefängnisbehörden verlassen er lebt
im Ausland hat eine Arbeit und eine
Wohnung gefunden für seine Krankheit
nimmt er
Medikamente fühlt er sich
geheilt ich bevorzuge das Wort stabil
man könte sagen dass ich stabil bin wenn
ich meine Medikamente nehme und einen
gesunden Lebens
beehalte ich betrachte es so wie wenn
ich eine chronische Krankheit hätte wie
Diabetes wo eine langfristige
medikamentöse Behandlung notwendig
ist Artikel
59 Artikel 64 Absatz 1 die ordentliche
Verwahrung keiner der beiden bietet in
den Augen von adelins Angehörigen
genügend Schutz vor dem Mörder ihrer
Tochter
ihre Hoffnung zum Zeitpunkt des
Prozesses gegen Fabris a lag auf Artikel
64 Absatz 1 bis der lebenslänglichen
[Musik]
Verwahrung sie ist die strengste
Maßnahme des schweizerischen
Strafgesetzbuchs
Urlaub und vorzeitige Haftentlassung
sind hier ausgeschlossen eingeführt
wurde die lebenslängliche Verwahrung
2004 im Rahmen einer
Volksinitiative
diese Maßnahme wird von vielen Juristen
als menschenrechtswidrig
angesehen bisher wurde sie nur ein
einziges Mal
angewendet das ist eine so extreme
Maßnahme dass sie jedes Recht auf
Hoffnung
nimmt das heißt was immer auch der
Häftling unternimmt um an sich zu
arbeiten es gibt keine Aussicht auf
Vergebung
eine lebenslängliche Verwahrung bedeutet
dass man jemanden quasi in die
Todeszelle steckt weil er nichts mehr
vom Leben zu erwarten
hat das Recht auf Hoffnung zu nehmen
bedeutet in gewisser Weise ihm den Tod
einzuhauchen soll man auf die Barbarei
eines Verbrechens mit der Barbarei einer
Bestrafung Antworten das ist die
Frage
unsere Tochter wurde zu lebenslänglich
verurteilt hätte noch 50 Jahre Mutter
sein können unser Tochter wurden also 50
Jahre mit ihr genommen das ist auch ein
lebenslänglich das Leiden von mir von AD
Eltern und Geschwistern ist
lebenslälich bei ihm weiß man das
nicht adelin wurde vor 10 Jahren
ermordet 10 Jahre in denen ihre
Angehörigen Tag für Tag den Verlust
spüren und eine große
[Musik]
Angst er hat keine lebenslängliche
Verwahrung das heißt dass er ab 15
Jahren Haft alle Z Jahre neu beurteilt
wird als Manipulator wird er Einfluss
auf seine Umgebung
besonders wenn vergessen geht was er
getan
hat ich kann nicht in Frieden sterben im
Bewusstsein dass er eines Tages erneut
unserer Familie oder anderen Menschen
Schaden zufügen
kann das macht mir so viel Angst dass
ich nicht in Frieden sterben
[Musik]
kann